hoho that's what it's what we came here
for that's what we came here for that is
not what we came here for hey what's
going on everybody for first we feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones it's the show with hot questions
and even had her wings and today we're
joined by NBA superstar Jimmy Butler
he's a four-time all-star and one of the
best defensive players in the NBA but
Holly endl full-court press of spicy ass
chicken wings we'll find out today Jimmy
buckets welcome to the show thank you I
know that you're a Texas man how do you
handle your heat this it's not it's not
me spicy foods we'll find out very
shortly I'll tell you that no pressure
but you all embiid your teammate came in
here crush the wings of death no
pressure I'm just saying yes basically
what you're saying is I I definitely
have to make it through all ten of these
wings
[Music]
here we go
please please please all of you pass out
it helped me more as late get better
[Music]
so earlier this year you launched a
YouTube channel and I'll go on record as
saying as if this basketball thing
doesn't work out you have a really
bright future as a travel vlogger what's
the most mind-blowing thing you learned
about wine when you visited the
Sassicaia winery in Florence Italy we
snuck up on me right there Hey Jude I
forgot the question you just asked
focused and I'm gonna try not to let it
hurt me too bad no damn I would have to
say how everything goes into it how it
rained at a certain time how it was so
hot at a certain time how the breeze
from the ocean came in at a certain time
oh it snowed a little bit how all this
stuff matters so that's how they can
tell you know what years are gonna be
like other years because they tracked
the weather for the most part I mean I
was listening in to a lot of it but then
it just started going over my head
because I was opposed at it and I just
drink the stuff but it was it was
interesting but just say that I have a
career afterwards doing the whole travel
vlog thing I appreciate it I'll bring
you on my on my youtube all right I'll
hold you to that I'll do that you can do
it
do you remember the first time that you
ever had $1,000 plus bottle of wine like
did it really taste that different that
much better than all the ones he'd had
before well I was I was spoiled for the
first one that I ever drank Mark
Wahlberg introduced me to Sesa Chaya
2010 was the first bottle that I had
that's all I've basically really ever
known son had it set a high taste hey
you know in college I didn't drink the
box more like everybody would say we're
straight off the Hennessy straight off
the Courvoisier and Arkan jerk holiday
good stuff
and now it's like I don't even drink
liquor like that it's just all why
[Music]
so few players read this constant upward
momentum in the league going from a 30th
overall pick to a four-time all-star
when you think of all the vets that
you've played with can you point to one
that really stands out as helping you to
unlock your potential I would say two
guys one obviously luau who are they who
I still talk to to this day that's my
that's my guy
three guys I take their back Rip
Hamilton was that absolute best at just
telling me the truth every single day yo
Jimmy how you doing I'm good how are you
all right now that the people part is
out the way he was on some [ __ ] here
you saw that boys did you do that I was
like the him rip like I asked me like my
body hurts didn't care he just wanted me
to be the best player that I could be
love him for that and man Kirk higher II
like that guy and you talk about
toughness that [ __ ] inspired the hell
out of me watching Kurt go at it with
with the best who sets the hardest
screens in the NBA
Stephen Adams yeah easily DJ DeAndre
Jordan doing his elbow he tore some
ligaments in his elbow one year he said
a Sereno me now we're like best buds but
at that point in time we're friends I
wanted to break his [ __ ] nose do you
have a favorite Brian Scalabrine memory
from your time with the Chicago Bulls
probably just how I used to beat his ass
one-on-one white Mamba that's this thing
like oh my mama I am the second coming
of Kobe I think Scout got the worst of
my one-on-one days back there I love you
Scout thank you for that scowl oh my god
and then finally what do you think is
the biggest difference between a college
player and his relationship to his coach
and an NBA player in his relationship to
his coach is it different
oh yeah it's different Buzz Williams
who's a lot like Tibbs in the sense that
they're gonna yell at you they're gonna
[ __ ] you they're gonna say it all
you know and that's how they talk to you
I think in the league you can't really
talk to nobody like that you know what I
mean like yeah it's like I feel like a
child actor and you're making more than
your parents exactly can't tell you to
clean your room
I did not say that so you're not gonna
say that I said that I tell these the
kids not to clean that room something
like that yeah it's it's tough to yell
at a grown man who potentially is making
more money in you not saying that you
shouldn't listen to people but I it's a
it's a different level
I'm in your wing on the next one cuz
you're not you're not fazed by this one
kind of switch it right now let's lunch
no no I just want one wing okay let's
watch our fours
yeah okay you trust me I watch your
hands I felt you okay perfect
you didn't ask if I trust you but I
would just going do you trust me
of course I do so there's this thinking
that hip-hop rules the MBA whether it's
Jay Cole showing up at the dunk contest
or LeBron rapping on his IG story but I
know for you
country music sits on the throne when
you think about all the locker room aux
cord fights you've gotten into over your
love of country music is there a story
that stands out we did hit that point
we're gonna hit that point you're not
gonna give me they told me not to drink
nothing I don't know why you got this
here put this on your son I'm not doing
another all right thinner arms reach if
you end up in a bad place Jimmy tell you
what I would say the one story that I
have comes from a knives Muhammad I knew
that he was recording me but I didn't
think that he would post it anywhere and
so you know I mean they're dancing
they're singing to myself in my bag in
my zone and I say I know there's a viral
video of me going around listen to
Taylor Swift am I happy about it yeah
cuz I like the song I love country music
I am Who I am that's why there's two
before games as anybody to tell you I
like it
[Music]
so everyone loves to tell the story of
Michael Jordan getting cut from his
varsity team when he was a sophomore but
your stories of triumph I really think
are the hoop dreams that more people
should talk about in a counterintuitive
way do you think that plane at a junior
college gave you a competitive edge when
you entered the NBA when you go to Tuco
it's like legit a dog-eat-dog world I
have you pass that ball in junior
college you may not know it not may not
you probably won't get it back like
that's the way that you go because
everybody's trying to get to that next
love right rightfully so to get to
division one from there and continue to
get better every year
but JUCO is fun when you think of some
of the hard-nosed grind-it-out players
that have been in the NBA whether it's
Bill Laimbeer Charles Oakley or Kevin
Garnett do you feel a kinship do you
feel like maybe that type of competitor
is less common these days I think so
nowadays I think it's a problem no I
just think the game has changed and it's
gonna change again in I don't know 10 15
20 name it but you still got guys is
swinging at each other as we can tell
from what Ibaka got in 2000 ight that's
highlight right yeah I love it
I think that even though the game has
changed you still got you still got
something that old bread that's that's
mixed in the new guys
[Music]
my way all right Jimmy every current
segment on our show called explain that
grammar we do a deep dive on our guests
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture you
just tell me the bigger story does that
sound good
oh my Instagram yeah oh snap we uh
cyberstalk yeah imagine all right first
things first what did you an AI talked
about you guys talked about practice no
I I we were talking about a conversation
that we had an all-star when we were in
LA actually right before this Jersey
SWAT we're laughing at the fact that
every time we come together he's always
like yo you fit Philly you a dog but
every single time were for work that's
it and look at us now so he called that
at like an all-star game years ago he
just said you fit Philly he did not say
yo come to Philly like cuz that's
tampering and none of that happened he
just saw the T leads me on to the future
he said he saw a smart man we love a
good mj's story do you remember the
first time you ever met Michael Jordan
in this particular photo he did win this
shootin contest
he chose a kid I chose a kid but it's
his camp so he knows what kids achieve
right he saw the kids shoot and he saw
so I'm like okay cool
excuse me sneak up all right um so in
this particular he did win but it didn't
show the other times that I actually won
that's the thing that got me like all
the video that came out isn't one of him
just busting my ass with his kids and I
was like what about the other three
times we played that me and the kid I
picked actually won that just goes to
show you that Richard Graham ain't worth
a damn Deebo that's mom
there right there would you do with the
gold medal it's at home wrapped in a
towel and my second drawer from the top
to the far left that's for one of the
most special moments to me just because
I never thought that I would be in the
NBA never thought that I would have a
division 1 scholarship never thought I'm
making out a junior college don't get me
wrong but with all that I said that I
done you never be able to tell me that
I'd be Olympic gold medalist I don't
know everything like that [ __ ] that's
that's the best photo what's it like
training Antonio Brown and Russell
Wilson humbling I'm a competitor I still
think of him it's like $30,000 because I
made a bet that I could stop him from
catching the ball in the red zone didn't
work out for ya you know you're talking
about the best receiver in the league
and then process a quarterback just
saying if if the Raiders had me
obviously to him I never know where we
could go well I did see you smoked klay
Thompson on that go round and want to
talk about that but since you brought it
up he can't guard me on the football
field either
[Music]
[Music]
Adobe Loco Kalou hey kid mandala is
better than I thought it would I should
probably not say that cuz I'm a jinx
myself I feel there's no give me but for
now I think I'm okay so over the past
few years you've become a frequent
target of this sort of sports talk radio
criticism and I'm curious I love it you
love it what do they get wrong about you
and when are they right I mean in what
parts you have you probably know it you
did your research so so like give me
something that you would say oh they say
this they say that well let's take maybe
that Timberwolves practice okay miss
Timberwolves practice for example you
know does the reaction to that story
surprise you with how big it was does it
surprise me
no nothing surprises me nowadays just
because of social media like if this was
before the social media age you wouldn't
know about it
I mean we probably would be sent here in
hot wings together either but I think
that all of that blows it out of
proportion
now do I talk [ __ ] a lot in practice yes
do I take it there no I was just in the
zone like I love basketball so much like
I I was competing at a high level and
then BOOM it happened but unless you're
with me every day and you see how I go
about what I do you'd understand why I
care so much like this morning at 4:00
when I was up getting ready to go lift
go shoot and go do Pilates a lot of
people asleep I'm at a different point
in my career than I am now
then I was in 2011 when I entered Elite
and if I play whether or not it didn't
matter I want to be a hunt like that all
the time but I can't I mean I can but I
probably should that's it
this woman though it looks fright sack
all on the same page
[Music]
I pitted me off because it looked like
honey mustard that's in there honey
mustard definitely not definitely not
yes we foe
that's what it's what we came here for
it's what we came here for that's not
what we came here for
so it small document that you and Mark
Wahlberg have this BFF relationship for
the ages I see guys golfin and France
are playing with dusty wine cellar
bottles remember they were sort of crud
over the show yeah many people you
wouldn't be the first won't be the last
you let it fly
but at least it looked like I'm crying
about me and marks friendship because
it's a beautiful thing if I were to
start crying that's right
to this day I it's the craziest story I
think whenever I talk cools down like I
said we're going back in time to
September 13th 2013 but so he came out
to the Bulls park facility and deer
field and for some reason he's going
around the wall he'd say y'all wanna I
want to play with him and we ended up
plant me and his crew then he was like
you know tomorrow you should come to the
set and check out transformers because
that's the movie I was filming and then
we went and watched a boxing match fluid
against somebody is September 14th of
2013 and then the crazy part is he gave
me his number data machine this one
he gave me a number because I yeah no
problem man you know whenever you come
to LA come by the house I was like what
and so you know I get to LA times like
yo I'm here here's a cool come by the
crib here to pick up this baseball bat
and hit the hit home run he could do it
kick this soccer ball and to the he
could do it marks one of those people
he's special man he's special
well shout-out Mark Wahlberg are you
ready to move on no every time you ask
me that question I I say no and I damn
sure don't wanna bite it in this one but
you keep moving on though and I
respected owner
you heard him pipes your death
[Music]
yep yeah I know how to react how you
were yet
holy
you know drink nothing you put them over
here they're within reach I have this
weird habit of always just mirroring the
guests no I don't do that because I'm
gonna marry you so if you mirror me and
I marry you and neither one of us don't
see then we're just stuck in a standoff
we're stuck in a milk standoff we're
going in for the milk Cheers oh yes
Cheers
how much do I drink
[Music]
look good good swag you know I'm lactose
intolerant so if I start breaking win
it's okay you get a long leash on this
show you get a long leash on the show
are you still playing the grocery store
game whereby you'll buy the groceries
for whoever's behind you regardless of
how big their cart is I have a man who I
don't haven't been to a grocery store in
a long time but when I do go yes do that
my answers are friend gets shorter and
shorter cousin I have I'm not close but
he thinks the biggest bill you've ever
had to foot
probably about five miles yeah and then
you know you often demonstrate your man
of the people's sensibilities even in
your car you know in the MBA this place
where everyone's got a wraith or a
Bentley or an Escalade
you'll still pull up in a minivan why is
the minivans still the king of the road
for you careful around your eyes Oh
[Music]
you're Elmo's Odie mm-hmm you taught me
I love the minivan it's real you don't
know it for me it has my baby on board
sticker in the back there's no baby on
board
but that's smart you're not on everyone
off the trail don't know off I do have
some other car so but des that's what
I'm in majority at a time I know you're
not ready for the next one
sorry Q just where's my the next one's
ready for you this is Hellfire fear this
I'm glad y'all getting a [ __ ] kick
out of this back
we are not gonna know touch my lips just
I'm alright
can y'all hear me from a key so I know
that you're an avid jet setter and the
offseason traveling around the world
from the beaches of mykonos all the way
to China between you Russell Westbrook
and Dwayne Wade who got the best fit
picks off at last year's Paris Fashion
Week we're gonna put myself in third I
love you it's that minivan man right
there right
do you waiting in rust they really do it
I spend a lot of time at fashion shows
and all that good stuff
and they do it the right way I would
tell you that one low light it'd be so
hot at them damn fashion shows I sweat
easily when the lights is on if it's hot
I can't do it and I'm hot I can't
function which is why I can't function
right now cuz my whole body is on fire
for me and he's hot winner but I would
say a highlight is that the night that
we got to drink a lot of wine together a
lot of stories told a lot of memories
made when Gabrielle Union was on the
show she said that Carmelo Anthony is
the real wine connoisseur of the NBA did
you guys try any bottles during that
trip to France we tried a lot of bottles
the one bottle that nobody got to try
because Carmelo Anthony's had to walk
away with this bottle was a bottle of
the truce he liked me there was
literally lined up like these hot sauce
bottles and um protrusions in the middle
and it was like the last bottles that
nobody drank so we're thinking like Oh
after we take these photos we're gonna
all sit back down and then we're gonna
the per truce is the one you don't have
anything for last
all of a sudden Melo was like all right
minutes that's a good evening let's all
go and nobody's realized that nobody's
drank that bottle of wine yet so
everybody's like yeah let's go good
night man good people go on as we're
leaving at the corner of my eye I see
Melo over posing with the bottle of the
truce and it's just like oh damn Melo
got the the best of the best but that
was
really good night the gondola boats in
Venice overrated or underrated what are
you doing
[Music]
gondola boats overrated or underrated
what are you doing well this is the last
dab Jimmy Butler
we call it the last tab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to now come on now you
know I have to but with that being said
I think it is from me I think the boats
are overrated as you can tell from what
on man I'm getting too much about it
there there we go
all right
[Music]
Google's nothing here it goes
[Music]
I did it I do all right Jimmy Butler
here we are at the end of the line
fourth quarter time running out I know
that for Jimmy buckets when it starts to
heat up like it is right now
that means that it's bandana season so
here on wing 10 someone bringing the
bandanas
I need a step-by-step tutorial on how to
sport the best possible bandana for
eating scorching hot chicken wings
I got you so first you fold it in half
this way like this right here
[Music]
then you just you just kind of rolling
it up no it looks better whenever I have
braids the honey's like it when I gotta
breed you and then just get a little
roll yeah it's good
like this right here
keep going a little bit put on anything
tuck it a little bit like that dirt
[Music]
yeah let's do this
[Music]
Wow it feels right it fits perfect I
think that this might be the look going
forward and look at you Jimmy Butler
going ten wings up ten wings down just
like your teammate Joelle embiid and
with even less of a sweat like Rocky you
look exactly like Rocky at the top of
the steps and now there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you Jimmy buckets this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life you
tell you what Jimmy Butler is on YouTube
y'all go check it out I'm stoked right
now that I made it through these ten
wings not gonna lie I didn't even think
I was gonna make it so I don't even know
what to say I really don't I don't
poor that dog they come to all the
Philly games cuz we need all the fans
that we can get hungry yeah I mean it's
always great but you know what I mean
it's a special kind of red today hey
what's going on everybody this is Sean
Evans checking in with a quick hot sauce
update if you'd like to try the classic
louis calientes the last abra ducks heat
nests calm heat nice calm has you
covered if hot sauce isn't your thing
maybe check out a t-shirt or a hoodie
over at shop complex calm and if none of
that interests you I have been really
getting into macho lately matcha latte
as much as smoothies matcha pudding I
don't know how I went 32 years on this
planet without discovering matcha but
now I have and it has been a complete
GameChanger
we don't sell any matcha products
whatsoever but I'm just saying you
should try it out